[Applaudissements]
venez nous sauver c'est le cri de
détresse des propriétaires de ce resto
self dans la banlieue d'orléans un
établissement situé au milieu d'une zone
d'activités
repris par nathalie et michel bugat il y
à 11 ans une affaire qui tourne est très
bien mais depuis la crise sanitaire rien
ne va plus chez nous des desserts c'est
que les clients reviennent mais très
lentement et paraît à même fréquence
donc on a peut-être vu à peu près
l'ensemble de nos clients mais au lieu
de venir chaque jour parfait mais je me
dis que l'on faisait avant ils viennent
une fois deux fois voire pas du tout on
a moins 40 % d'activité de juin à
septembre
malgré des menus inférieur à 10 euros le
self est loin de faire le plein j'ai de
la choucroute cuisse de poulet poisson
meunière aujourd'hui il ya un creux on
voit que ça va pas est une grosse
journée je pense qu'on va faire dans
l'est et peut-être 90 son dif donc voilà
on continue à baisser un peu ya une
année normale ont fait normalement au
mois d'octobre entre 150 et 100 400
clients
crise sanitaire oblige les clients n'ont
plus les mêmes réflexes j'avais pris
d'autres habitudes je faisais des
courses j'avais vraiment changé mes
habitudes mais je reviens plus qu'avant
l'état nous demande de réfléchir au sein
des entreprises de mettre en place le
télétravail donc la journée suivant les
entreprises ça déjà ça va réduire sa
marée duire leur potentiel
mais je les paie
ici comme pour de nombreux
établissements qui ouvre seulement le
midi la baisse de fréquentation est un
coup dur malgré l'obtention des pg e les
prêts garantis par l'état sur 300
millions euros 310 millions euros de
chiffre d'affaires qu'on fait dans une
année normale on a perdu trois cent
vingt mille euros de chiffre d'affaires
sur 18 mois
donc l'état à combler à auteur d'à peu
près quatre mois 120000 euros lots
restent bas le reste on a pioché dans la
trésorerie hong a fallu faire un pga
parce que les assurances nous faisons
pas remboursés et manants bas maintenant
il faut commencer à rembourser tout ça
une situation que notre restaurateur vie
de plus en plus mal
je pense qu'on va vers on va vers un
drame style les agriculteurs avec des
suicides à l'impact dans la restauration
je n'imagine pas que les gens puissent
prendre ça comme ça comme une lettre à
la poste ciao bonsoir si votre seconde
c'est pas possible pas dans nos métiers
[Musique]
150 km plus au sud à château dans le
berry l'escale est un routier connu dans
toute l'europe et pour cause il est
ouvert 365 jours par an 24 heures sur 24
enfin ça c'était avant car depuis trois
mois
la célèbre enseigne connaît aussi de
sérieuses difficultés
on était une brigade et 85 90 on se
retrouve à 60 j'ai des bons des bons
termes et les personnes qui sont parties
souvent dans d'autres métiers parce
qu'ils n'ont pas attendu la fin du coc
vide ils ont fait des formations ils ont
été travaillés comme cariste
manutentionnaire c'était que des gens
courageux en attendant le chef forme des
plongeurs au métier de cuisinier le
restaurant a même lancé une campagne de
recrutement sur paris qui n'a rien donné
ce que je ne comprends pas c'est qu'avec
le nombre de chômeurs qui en france il
ya personne qui veut remplacer ces gens
là c'est ça le drame tout le monde va le
restaurant mais personne ne travaille au
restaurant alors voyez là nous on a la
chance d'avoir un groupe de 45 50
personnes 60 personnes qui sont encore
aux pme qui veulent encore été chez nous
faute de personnel les ce qu'elle a dû
fermer ses portes la nuit pour la
première fois de son histoire pour les
chauffeurs routiers c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle
ces gens qui font du rungis que le sud
ouest sud il s'arrêtait beaucoup la nuit
pour manger assez rapide une demi heure
non c'est permis et plus rien tout est
fermé c'est une page qui se tourne on a
l'impression quand même bar vert
une époque où je pense que là aussi les
gens peut-être ont une réflexion par
rapport au temps de travail par rapport
à la famille par rapport à tout ça on
sacrifie beaucoup de choses en
travaillant le week end
certains prônent des solutions radicales
[Musique]
arrêtez de dz les aides on n'en veut
plus ces bons bloquer tous les gens
voulaient mettre au travail et voilà
c'est fini on coupe les vivres à tout le
monde et après c'est bon parce que tout
le monde ira retravaillé pour 1100 euros
ou 800 euros par mois et là dans la
cuisine demain il y aura du monde
en attendant des jours meilleurs
al'approche de minuit la salle se vide
le veilleur de nuit s'apprête à prendre
son service et dominique thomas le
patron à une nouvelle tâche quotidienne
la fermeture du rideau de fer
mais drôle d'époque une chose qui s'est
cassé quoi
ça va se réparer c'est à coire il faut
le croire il croire
[Musique]
nous sommes à paris dans les locaux du
cabinet gira spécialisé depuis 30 ans
dans le conseil aux restaurateurs son
fondateur bernard boutboul pointe l'une
des causes du manque de personnel on a
aujourd'hui deux jeunes sur trois qui
abandonne dans les deux ans après leur
sortie de l'école hôtelière c'est
dramatique ça veut dire quoi
concrètement ça veut dire qu'on les
forme et quand ils vont sur le terrain
ils s'aperçoivent que ce n'est pas ce
qu'on leur a appris et qu'ils ont une
mauvaise surprise tout ce qui se passe
sur le terrain
direction le lycée hôtelier de blois
l'un des meilleurs de france
les élèves de cette classe de terminale
sont préparés à la fois à cuisiner et au
service en salle alors aujourd'hui le
service vous proposant un menu sur le
thème du zéro déchet de lentilles
gaspillage chaque midi ils reçoivent de
vrais clients dans l'un des trois
restaurants d'application de
l'établissement parce que on attend de
se faire une vraie expérience ou pouvoir
vraiment si ça nous plaît avant de
s'inquiéter pour l'avenir je pense
l'envi d'abord de nos passions et on va
voir plus tard si on peut revivre ou pas
un temps d'étude que beaucoup d'entre
eux considèrent aussi comme un temps de
réflexion sur leur avenir dans la
profession ce que je peux totalement
changé après deux sorties de parce que
j'aimerais bien faire un bts
e
en alternance option service et donc
après je suis pas sûr forcément de
continuer vers la restauration mais
peut-être que oui comme ça me chante le
ceba
cap tartare calcul et de rats des quatre
heures près de la moitié des jeunes
diplômés dans le secteur quittent la
profession dans les cinq ans est-elle
encore adapté aux jeunes générations
réponse sans tabou franchement en étant
honnête très honnête
moi personnellement j'ai travaillé dans
le privé donc pendant 12 ans et j'ai
effectivement changer de métier parce
que ça commence à devenir un petit peu
trop compliqué physiquement moralement
mentalement et puis on se rend compte
qu'on est vraiment
à l'écart de la société quand la société
part en vacances vous travaillez
inversement un statut et des horaires
inadaptés un salaire insuffisant mais
pas seulement le management est aussi
pointée du doigt par cette cliente dont
le fils a quitté la profession
ah ben oui ça doit changer parce que cet
esclavage
ils veulent plus
les élèves du lycée hôtelier effectue
pourtant de nombreux stages dans les
restaurants mais c'est parfois
insuffisant pour évaluer les difficultés
du métier sur une longue période
sans métier si difficile mais qui est
rempli de passion ici on est ici on
m'arrête ici son art est pourtant coup
c'est normal parce qu'on est on est plus
passionné ou alors on a un manque de
motivation
[Musique]
pour certains la crise sanitaire a été
l'occasion d'innover
maxime retour à orléans dans cet espace
de coworking qui a ouvert il ya
seulement six mois dans l'entrée un
distributeur d'un genre nouveau c'est
maxime voisins le créateur du restaurant
de sel et dardoise qu'il approvisionne
les commandes on les suit en direct au
restaurant fait à moi chaque fin de
service du midi je jette un oeil pour
savoir qu'est ce qui a été vendu dont on
vient quasiment pas tous les jours tous
les 48 heures
tous remplis rosa gaillot la responsable
du lieu et la première séduite à
dégoûter le petit gâteau l'ananas il
hier était situé dans
le distributeur des bocaux repas
préparés dans la cuisine du restaurant
avec des produits frais et locaux il
fallait qu'on trouve une formule assez
assez souple donc d'où là l'idée de ceux
de ce distributeur où je voulais quand
même des choses assez qualitative en
termes de cuisine et puis une idée aussi
c'était de pouvoir faire travailler du
loco donc voilà c'est comme ça que ça
m'est venu assez assez naturellement de
pouvoir travailler avec maxime chaque
utilisateur choisit un plat un dessert
ou un fruit à l'aide des photos de 2
euros 50 pour les desserts à 7 euros
pour les plats cette restauration séduit
je trouve que ça change en fait d
ce gâteau sous cellophane ou des
sandwichs et niang le fameux ton jambon
beurre etc on a l'impression de manger
de
comment dire de la restauration
gastronomique
dans un distributeur donc c'est plutôt
agréable
les plats en bocaux maxime et sa femme
claire les conçoivent dans la petite
cuisine de leur restaurant à orléans
avant les confinements la salle
proposait 20 places assises aujourd'hui
il n'en reste que 8
car pour le jeune couple aussi la crise
sanitaire a bouleversé la façon de
concevoir le métier on peut digitalisées
aujourd'hui maintenant avec tous les
moyens qu'on a le vrai souci de base ça
reste quand même ou est-ce qu'on se
place au niveau de la qualité est ce que
l'on fait de la restauration pour juste
part de l'argent qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour nourrir les gens ce qu'on fait pour
bien nourrir les gens et est ce qu'on
fait pour nourrir le plus grand nombre
le mieux possible et pour faire
différemment il a fallu revoir jusqu'à
la conception des recettes
de 10 go on n'avait cure et de l'année
et haddock fumé
on est plutôt sur la simplicité des
produits mais quand même travaillé
élaboré on a dû réadapter
notre cuisine pour le pouvoir la faire à
emporter et qu'elle soit quand même
relativement facile et accessible aux
gens et qu'ils puissent facilement la
réchauffer à la maison
aujourd'hui les bocaux représente près
de 80% de l'activité du couple contre
20% pour le restaurant
l'avantagent on ne peut continuer à bien
manger à manger des choses qu'il nous
faut donc désavantagés de plus pouvoir
tenir sur place et c'est quand même
c'est quand même différent cet appareil
de le manger à la maison on l'a vu ça
sur facebook et des amis qui nous en ont
parlé donc on a on avait envie d'essayer
donc là on a vu qu'il y avait des
cheminots qui nous tente est sur la
carte les nouvelles habitudes des
consommateurs force les professionnels a
changé l'innovation sera digital mais
pas seulement selon bernard boutboul
il y aura demain des restaurants de
plaisir d'échanger le convivialité qui
seront des restaurants que l'on appelle
expérientiel et puis il y aura une autre
façon de se nourrir qui sera puisqu'il
n'ya pas d'expérience à aller chercher
si untel ou untel qui sera uniquement
digitalisées où je me ferais livré à la
maison je me ferais livré au bureau et
les la génération z nous dit me faire
livrer d'ailleurs ailleurs qu'au bureau
et ré maison la génération z nous dit je
comprends pas qu'on puisse pas se faire
livrer au coin de la rue ou dans la
forêt
digitalisées festif au restaurant ou pas
leur part est une tradition française
même si les professionnels doivent se
réinventer pour survivre la crise
sanitaire n'aura fait qu accélérer les
mutations en cours au risque de
multiplier les fermetures
[Musique]